how do you like being on this side of
the alley being interviewed Peterson off
the great actor once I assume that if
you like being interview he said I love
being interviewed because it makes me
think about things I don't think about
as I don't drive around all day
interviewing myself so it forces you to
think so when when you're asked good
questions as you've been asking good
questions it forces me to think and like
to think when there's stupid questions
no then bad not throw a little I've had
some of those yeah by the best instance
that was I was touring a book I wrote
I've written 16 books I was turning the
book and I was on the show called good
morning Dallas I could tell you right
away you can I can tell you right away
you know what the host and hostess look
like I don't tell you know something in
my mind
generic guy was that perfectly coughed
here and the woman had blonde hair
puffed around yeah and the woman was
scheduled to interview me and as she's
asking requite I can see that she's
really loved the questions on a piece of
paper he's not listening to my answers
and while I'm answering it she's like
fishing her hair and the crew is living
I'm answering the questions is a fourth
question was what makes a good talk-show
host and I say well I don't know about
other people I can tell she's not
listening but what helps me the most is
being in the CIA because by being in the
CIA what happens is they they get me
great guests and I can tip off spies
around the world and then she goes on to
another thing well raising children is
that that that's yeah and you don't
think she heard a word you were saying
it was no yeah uh well you've done
something right on this side of the
table too because I haven't looked at my
notes one so I'm feeling pretty good
about this so my final question to you
is uh I can I can tell people you're 80
years old right that's that's public had
a big that's public relations party was
a bad play Dodgers stating with that as
bigger thrill for you your baseball guy
was that
the shop yeah at the same time mister my
wife pulled it off I don't know how she
pulled it off that said all those people
up yeah to walk into that Stadium I
thought I was going to a meeting of
season ticket holders was a logical they
had a great ploy yeah I had a letter
from the Dodgers to me season ticket
holder come on Friday night was my
birthday birthday was coming four days
later hmm I thought she was going to do
something on my birthday night I was on
Jimmy Kimmel on my actual birthday and
that was booked a long time ago so I
thought they were taking me somewhere
after Jimmy Kimmel right that's what I
thought so it totally threw me yeah and
they had like almost 300 people at at
home plate people that kids in uniform
playing baseball the stadium's all lit
up my thing up on the scoreboard I
couldn't believe I could I just I just I
couldn't believe so but I can see it in
your eyes I mean baseball really is
yours I grew up with it it's a trizzyb
my boys play it
the biggest thrill I get in my life is
watching my kids yeah I was not a good
athlete a baseball fan like last
Saturday
my son pitched for Notre Dame freshman
he's in Wow first one in high school and
I watched him on the mound and he's you
know like as one guy sitting next to me
says wave that kids a ballplayer just
the way he moves he's got swagger and he
baseball doesn't move an athlete has you
can know if a guy's a player he's a
player just the way he comes out of the
dugout the way he handles his glove the
way he looks at was any pitch shutout
innings he only struck out the side in
the first inning and I'm sitting there
and I'm the Jewish term is felling yeah
quelling is when you get a throw for
something else happened to someone you
care about and I was remembering the his
birth I cut the cord
I cut that I don't think we didn't do
the forest get yourself in no no okay I
cut and I so I'm born and now he's 15
years old
pitching for Notre Dame on a beautiful
high school field you know sort of feel
like this they put was just how could
you top that so nothing I bet did in the
eighty years nothing tough that well I
think you've answered my final question
here but how I wanted to end this was
what do you think my grandma would
always say what's it all about Alfie so
what do you think 80 years you've
interviewed live literally everybody
from every walk of life you've talked to
everybody listened to everybody now a
father the whole thing what do you think
it's all about at the end of the day
what do you think you know what there
was a famous Nobel Prize winner who
lived to 95 years old and he was at a
dinner table and someone said I forget I
shouldn't forget is that when you're 80
you start to get up again what do you
know 95 years what do you know and he
said and I would put this as my epitaph
the only thing I know said I don't know
well on that was it all about Alfie I
don't know I asked Stephen Hawking this
was the smartest person in the world of
physicists hmm you're the smartest
person world what don't you know
what is something you don't know and he
said women ah I think he's married
though isn't he
yes he is I think he's married so that
of course you're married you know
exactly